[music]
>> There's an art of taking out mistakes.
There's an art. If you excel in the art
of taking out mistakes, you have reached
a very high level.
Taking out general mistakes is very
easy, but taking out mistakes with
reason, logic, and technical aspects.
Why are people coming more for that
person's talk? Why? What are the pros?
What are the cons?
We started observing non-Muslim
speakers.
Jimmy Swaggart.
Wow.
In technique, alhamdulillah, he's one of
the best speakers.
Jimmy Swaggart is the person who debated
with Sheikh Deedat.
And we'll discuss about him also.
Who has seen the video cassette of
Sheikh Deedat and Jimmy Swaggart?
Masha Allah.
Almost all of you.
Irrespective [clears throat] whether
he's your enemy,
you have to appreciate the good points
of your enemy.
And even Quran agrees with that.
Quran says, "Fas'alu Ahl az-Zikri in
kuntum la ta'lamun." Ask the person
who's knowledgeable. It doesn't say ask
the person who's a Muslim.
Yes, if you have a knowledgeable person
who's a Muslim, then that's the best.
But if the most knowledgeable person in
that field is a non-Muslim, no problem.
And
keeping that in mind,
we had
the second phase.
And with whatever
knowledge we could acquire,
we went ahead
with the second phase, and
alhamdulillah.
The unfortunate part is that whenever I
give a speech, before it goes out in the
public, I check it.
So, when I finished the Dawah training
program, it was very well planned,
much better planned than now.
1 year in advance, gave the ad about 9
months before. It took 3 months for
interview. We appointed separate people
in Malaysia, had interviews in a
three-star hotel or five-star, I don't
remember. Then in Saudi Arabia, we
appointed people. Here, we appointed.
There, we appointed. Took the interviews
on a one-to-one basis, and then selected
the creme de la creme. Then we started
getting invitations from different parts
of the world. Why don't you
do the program?
And
the person who came out first was from
Saudi Arabia,
Brother Faisal Kamali.
Then he went to states to do his
bachelor's.
He learned Hebrew, Aramaic, was very
good in English and Arabic. He went to
UK. When he started giving talks, people
said, "Ah, you look similar to Sheikh
Zakir Naik."
How did you know? No, you have the same
style.
Not that you have to be a ditto copy,
but
and yet he's in the field of Dawah.
May Allah give him jazak Allahu khair.
We realized that alhamdulillah,
we ventured into a thing which was
warned by
one of the greatest
da'is of the last century, Sheikh
Deedat.
But that doesn't mean he was wrong. He
was correct.
I remember my father,
we'll discuss that inshallah in the
organization part,
later on.
That many a time what people say,
if
you do the opposite and get success,
that doesn't mean they're wrong.
When I started the organization, my
father told me, "Son,
when you start an Islamic organization,
they will pull your leg. Tang
khechenge."
Be careful.
Alhamdulillah, we started, we were
successful.
But my father wasn't wrong. He was
right.
What Sheikh Deedat said,
that it's Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala who
creates da'is, he's right.
And then we do agree that
to spend your time, money, energy in
trying and choosing the people, and they
don't happen to be the right people,
it's a loss.
It's a loss to the ummah.
The money can be achieved, what about
the time?
Sheikh Deedat's 2 months is more
expensive than what he spent for the
course.
That time it was phenomenal.
And he's right.
I agree with him. I don't disagree with
him.
Alhamdulillah, Allah gave us success.
And Sheikh Deedat had many training
programs.
It was unfortunate that
Allah had his will that he trained many
people,
but none really shone out or
many da'is were there, became local.
Even now they have training programs,
but none of them reached anywhere close
to him or even a small percentage of
what he did.
So, he was sure that it's Allah who
creates, and he's right. Allah chooses.
But then we thought that if Allah wants
to choose,
why can't we be instrumental in making
Allah's plan come true?
So, my thinking was, Allah is going to
choose.
He's going to create. He can do kun
fayakun. Be, and it is.
He can do it
through IRF Dawah training program. That
was my thinking. This Sheikh Deedat is
right.
Maybe Allah wants to train only one
from these 20 people.
Fine.
Why don't we be that zariya?
We be that path and get easy thawab. You
know, easy shortcut.
Allah does the job.
Make hay while the sun is shining.
With that intention in mind, not that we
are the one who creates da'is. That's
the reason in this Dawah training
program,
I emphasize always,
this training program will be useless.
It is useless, will be useless, will not
benefit you, unless Allah helps you.
So, that's the reason the emphasis of
the training program was number one in
getting Allah's help.
Which, believe me, I've gone through
tens of Dawah training programs.
This point was never emphasized.
Yes, it said Allah is the Allah, you
know, but not that hammering.
Everyone says inshallah, Allah's mercy,
hadha min fadli Rabb. Who doesn't say
that?
Most of the da'is say, but not that
hammering.
That this is your master key. This is
your ace.
This is your key to success, Allah and
Allah alone, and no one else.
So, when we
devised this program, besides looking at
the technical aspects and the drawbacks
of the other training programs, they
give notes and writing notes and this
blah blah blah coming,
speaking for 2 hours, writing notes,
going home.
Okay, go home.
And none of them could
really speak.
And when you see the last day of the
training program of Sheikh Ahmed Deedat,
which we'll show you on the last day of
this training program,
you can compare. These da'is have been
trained for 2 months.
So, that is also a reference for us.
>> [snorts]
>> Spending so much money, so much time of
a person who could do wonders otherwise,
and see the result.
So, I agree with Sheikh Deedat 100%
without any
out of doubt that what he says is right.
It is Allah who chooses. So, what we do,
we take his advice.
We create a Dawah training program.
We refer to the best of skills, as Allah
says, "Go to an expert." And incorporate
in it, while teaching the skill, hammer
the point in it very well, it is Allah
and Allah alone, and no one else who can
make you an
effective da'i.
Dr. Zakir Naik is not the person.
It is Allah, Allah alone. Allah can make
Dr. Zakir Naik a zariya.
He can make him instrumental if he
pleases. Hadha min fadli Rabb.
Allah says in the Quran, it is only
Allah who gives hidayah. When Allah
revealed the verse, the verse of Surah
Ghashiyah, chapter number 88, "Fadhakkir
innama anta mudhakkir." Your job is to
deliver the message. Changing hearts is
in the hands of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Allah is telling Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam, the best human being
that lived on the face of the earth,
it is only Allah who can change the
heart, not you.
When this verse was revealed,
Hazrat Bilal, he laughed.
May Allah be pleased with him.
When the other people asked, "Why are
you laughing?" He said, "Alhamdulillah,
good. It is in the hands of Allah to
whom he's giving hidayah. Otherwise, me,
a black slave, would have come last in
the queue."
Imagine the time in which there was so
much of apartheidism,
black and white,
the color consciousness.
At that age, when Arabs looked down on
others,
imagine that black person, the Sahaba,
Bilal radiallahu anhu,
giving the adhan and people coming.
You know, when the kings of the other
countries came and saw, "What kind of
upside down religion is this?
If you're not standing straight in the
queue, the black man is touching me.
Stand correctly.
What kind OF A DEAL IS THIS?
THE black man calling me for prayers.
Waking up
the people.
Allah gave these things to Daya.
If you read the seal of the prophet
you'll find out
that when people send find out about
this man Muhammad Salah Salem.
They said
we have visited kings of Kasulu of
Persia. In the world we have never seen
a man who has been followed so sincerely
and so passionately by his followers.
Talking about the Sabbas.
At his word they are ready to leave the
things they like the best in the life.
People follow the king because they fear
they may not be given the things
or maybe punished but your people
die for him.
So it's Allah and Allah alone
who can give Daya.
And I do agree it's Allah and Allah
alone
who can give you success to be an
effective day.
So incorporating both these things
following chapter 3 verse 160
is one part of it the most important
second is driving.
Let's see
who's willing to sacrifice.
>> [music]
[music]